also in der ersten woche durfte was du
dir eigentlich da ich wir wollen noch
nie so oft gewürzt symbol das vielleicht
das einzige was ich so gut ist das
schnelle essen ich sehe jetzt zum mal
vorkommen beim zebrastreifen das so dass
dort alles schlicht mord dieses dreht
training ist ja dazu da dass wenn man
gestresst ist du nicht mehr überlegen
muss was gemacht wo soldaten muss immer
fuß egal ob jetzt schlechtes wetter ist
oder ob jetzt du noch was brennt also
und eben dieser frauen haben das habe
man bisher keine post das eigentlich
eher ein stressigen situationen mehr
gehen kann man bekommt seine art
feldmann wird zäher und die grenzen ganz
anders sind als man selber überhaupt
man glaubt so jetzt ist schluss aber es
ist dann noch lange schluss das geht
doch es gibt sehr sehr viele waren noch
nie so sänger nehmen also jetzt mitunter
sei es ist so
[Musik]
bis die spitze der ausbildung so aber
darum muss erstmal schießen mir gesagt
okay ist und nicht so witzig dass es
nicht beim thema datenschutz habt ihr
was menschen nicht unter den menschen
das herrschaftliche frage ist halt
niemand die waffe einsetzte
sondern eigentlich auf
selbstverteidigung
[Musik]
ich finde schon dass hier gerechter ist
als wenn sich irgendwo bewirbt und man
bekommt da nicht mal eine antwort mit
seinen ausländischen namen aber je mehr
ist es ruhig jeder die gleiche chance
das macht jeder das gleiche es muss
wieder das gleiche machen kameradschaft
ist ja auch wichtig weil du dich auf den
anderen verlassen mussten
ganz toll das wohl der gemeinschaft über
sein eigenes wohl zu stellen
das verfahren gespart machen und
vielleicht war pressen und riten
sandkasten wird wieder zu holen die
wieder rund laufen heute wieder lieb
egal wir ziehen das gemeinsam durch
bekommen gemeinsam ans ziel und wir
zurück gelassen und auch wenn ich der
rucksack schleppt das egal wir kommen
gemeinsam dieses so starker gestartet
[Musik]
komus afghanistan normalerweise da geht
da geht es ein bisschen anders
krieg ist nie gerecht also wenn
irgendwer wir herzlich zur waffe greifen
müsse eingegriffen wird dann ist das
irgendwie schon gerechtfertigt sich zu
verteidigen weil es geht ums erleben man
verteidiger nicht nur mit der waffe sein
eigenes lehrer sondern schuster seine
kameraden und star trek völker und seine
familie im endeffekt auch wir haben ja
einen frieden den wir bewahren wollen
das ist auch der grund warum das nun ist
er da ist mich selber wird nicht als
extrem patriotisch bezeichnen und ich
finde es aber sehr patriotisch wenn man
jetzt etwas verteidigt was an kostbar
ist und die finden es gibt viele
schützenswerte sind österreich jedes
winter im winter ferien viele genug
anderen motto urlaub
wenn ihn wiederzufinden österreich wegen
mir schon so weiß stetten ist weil es
ist mehr antritt
[Musik]